this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app do you
want to get paid five dollars and also
get five dollars to give to charity do
you want to give five dollars to charity
well yeah I mean I do because I'm a good
person
you may be or not but you still should
do it okay you want to buy and sell
Bitcoin instantly or get your paycheck
deposited right to the app all of us
babies use the cash app which is why
it's the number one finance app in the
App Store download the free cash app for
iOS or Android now and we are coming to
you from the past we're gonna put this
episode up today but we recorded it a
day ago now I'm going live on my app for
the subscribers and they're hearing this
podcast in the past they're already
heard the beginning of it I'm gonna do
the first ten minutes here on my app
which you could just type in crystally
at the app store and listen to the first
few minutes before it comes out if not
all good
but you got to wait like a plebian I I'm
wearing this shirt it says YUM for the
itch it's a fan made it and gave it to
me and I don't remember when they gave
it to me I think I was in wherever I was
last in Florida maybe but anyway it was
really cool oh no I was in South
Carolina
no was in Florida anyway have no idea
but they they gave it to me
and it's an ode to one of the podcast
episodes called YUM and it has to do
with the sorting skill episode were they
always saying I like to eat children yum
but yeah so it's Sunday today it's
finally being beautiful in Los
Angeles first of all let me tell you
before we be getting to the podcast I
had to do an interview for this radio
station and I did it and it was 30
minutes long and too long and one fire
and I even get rid of was sitting here
while I was doing the interview and my
voice is like gone already because of it
now I got
to an hour on the podcast dude what I'm
trying to tell you guys is my life is so
hard it's hard the wands the
Ivan and Vaughn Ivan and one or laughing
because they know my life is not hard
but I'm a big guy okay busy out of the
ten minute podcast I used to do with
Bryan Callen and Will Sasso who's the
busiest was the busiest we had an
episode called who is the busiest but
yeah so mm-hmm
did I talk about the Florida gigs
already I already did that right yeah I
don't know what dude how about this I
haven't known what day it is since I
graduated high school and if you know
what day it is
you have a office job straight
up you know who doesn't know what day it
is chicks on like Instagram they don't
know what day it is dude in LA chicks in
LA that Hawk herbal tea huh-huh ker they
don't know what day it is
you putting coffee scrub on your
body in the shower and you don't know if
it's Tuesday or Saturday you
have no clue hump day that just
means you're and it's everyday
hump day is hump day cuz it's hump and
day cuz you for cash the land
then then then I can't wait to run for
mayor and there's so much black and
white footage of me
Chris Thalia said Chris D'Elia what do
you really want him putting do you
really want him dealing with your kids
and their schools when this is what he
says and it plays a clip of me saying
I'd get in the ass for four
million dollars you know I didn't say
that but I'm just saying YUM my dogs are
here I got Sam and butters they're
chillin it work you know what I mean
dude
life is good but when the
weather is good and you wake up
and you just walk outside and you
literally just hear in your head
what I won't do cut and it might be hard
to handle and you're walking and a flame
burns a candle and you get in the car
and then you hear some any turn on the
radio and there's some
radio DJ and you're like that that could
adult my move mood a little bit and then
but you like but don't take it from me
man
don't take it from me I'm gonna just
drive I'm gonna go get my coffee you go
get your coffee and you get there and
there's some guy dressed all in mesh in
Hollywood and it and it pisses you off a
little bit but you're like you know what
don't take it from me man this day it's
a beautiful day I'm trying to listen to
some Halla notes in my head I'm
trying to live a montage style life I'm
trying to live that montage lifestyle
dude that's what I'm trying to do but
people get it you may be a
homeless guy yells at you with and and
spits on you a little bit you're like oh
now I have eight maybe that's that bad
to say now is that something that
they're going to play in black and white
when I run for mayor of Los Angeles yes
but do I care no because here let me
tell you something let me tell you what
Conor McGregor's gonna do and then let
me tell you what he should do all right
now everybody knows what he did he
took that chair and he threw it
into the bus and it cracked the bus and
now he turned himself in and he's a joke
now he's gonna do probably his apologize
now I don't think he should
apologize here's why apparently what
happened was these
have see fighters or fighters cornered
his friend and were like bullying him or
whatever threatening him or whatever
Conor McGregor which is the most Irish
thing you can do if you're rich God on a
jet flew to where this was well
confronted the guy who was in the bus at
the time took a chair threw it at the
bus now that's illegal we get it I would
never do it but if I did do it
what Conor McGregor should do instead of
apologizing say listen I know it was
illegal but somebody was with my
friend I got on a jet to come show these
what's up I know it's
illegal and I'm not sorry because I
would do it again that's what he should
say because that's what a down ass
does if Conor McGregor did
that you'd understand he would be the an
even bigger star when you apologize you
become this you become this
I'm not saying you should never
apologize I've done that's stupid
you know you apologize for that but that
that was being a
down-ass homie that's what he was being
so Irish so Irish is so rich to be like
I can't do an Irish accent I wish I
could but what did he say oh he's he he
said he cornered you ah I've got twenty
million dollars I've got twenty million
francs or whatever they have over there
now Frank's where they have Frank's is
German right I don't know I've got 20
million Irish dollars I've got 20
million euro what's probably 40 billion
40 billion euro you know how like
it's all different you go to
Mexico you're like what's two dollars
they're like it's 14 million pesos I'm
rich anyway I'm flying over I'm getting
on my jet I'm get on me jet and I'm
flying over and I'm throwing the first
chair I see into his bus yeah well he's
actually worth way more than 20 million
right
but yeah that don't apologize for
that car
down hey hey if that's what
happened he deserved it um yeah anyway
what was I even saying oh yeah the
if I run for mayor dude I'm not
sorry for any of this I don't know
that's all I'm saying but dude um you
know it's like it's like really cool
it's really cool that that happened and
it's it's bad for the UFC I guess but
it's good for it's good for it's good
for Conor McGregor if he spins it right
but what I do this week I had one thing
I actually forgot to tell you about was
the when I was in Florida I literally
had the most Cuban driver of all time
this blue bird reiver dude we wanted to
take a over to South Beach just to walk
around and see it and this guy was when
I got in he when I got in the ER he goes
like that first of all he was Sun
trustworthy which was which is for some
reason in my head it's a Cuban but I've
well I opened the door and he goes I
guess what's your name what's your name
like clapped what's your name I said uh
oh yeah my name my name is Chris okay
because you come in here because one
time the other day guy come in drive all
the way to for a load or dumb man I
didn't make that money man
it wasn't him I didn't get paid because
I didn't take him all the way to Fort
Lauderdale I said what what why the
would some random guy just get driven
all the way to Fort Lauderdale not tell
you who he was
it's a hour away he's a man and
I don't know man what a Cubans always I
don't know man
they put their pump so far behind the
front of their face man I don't know
it's my hands up this man man I don't
know man just trying to put my chest out
as much as I can put a puzzle my hands
way far back in there man that's what
I'm doing man
and he was saying you go to South Beach
man do you want to go to there what was
it called something cafe like Mambo cafe
whatever it was it was the most of Miami
Nahum name of all time you know by the
way does who does that Mambo
number 5 song Lou Bega this I feel like
that guy's always in Miami and never
sleeps just wearing a white suit
with a white hat down him down here now
is that that's him right we know that's
that's Mambo number 5 wait what am i
singing that's not that's mama number 5
is what's the what's what is
that song no Fantasia
yeah I get it I get it mixed up with
blue because I feel like Lou Bega would
be dancing to that song so that's
what the song is dancing to mmm all the
time but anyway um flip Fantasia yeah uh
well that song kind of sucks
you know anyway we did we did the
UM the ride and he was like you're going
to sell beat you gotta go to Ma mm
whatever was something like Mambo cafe
man you got you gotta go to air man
driving always with his hands behind his
head not even using the steering wheel
because he's so Cuban he had to keep his
hands behind his face opening our
palms out man we gotta go there man the
girls man that cars my friends this what
he was saying my friends like to go to
the strip club man you want to go to
strip where'd you go to this one man you
paid to $3.00 man you put it down man
one time I pay $80 at the time of Milan
but these strip clubs on the be man of
Miami man they think what for one and
you pay $400 for what got to see none
you man there's no word man but this is
what he was saying I didn't say anything
about a strip club but he was like you
gotta go to this one man if you wanna go
of the agreement to $3 $4 man for
throwing $3
dude he would get so violent immediately
like he would be like he would be like
he's he said uh-oh he's telling me how
to hit on girls he was away from a Guba
Guba they get it they get it they get it
you go up you'll be a little bit more I
got on my song I tell myself I'm 49 I
tell myself I tell my song too he says
um you know you be a little nice to the
girls you talk to them buying cool but
you can be a little bit more aggressive
by hearing my admit they don't care
you go up you say what's up let's do
this
and he goes like this he literally did
the most cute thing ever he goes like
this he did that next slit thing
like that was his you're not gonna get
laid sign its Cuban it was so funny dude
me and my opener were laughing the whole
time and we do the thing we do the
ultimate dude we were like egging
him on but he didn't know it we're like
oh yeah yeah yeah oh cool so it's like
that also what else then my friend I did
a bit on Cubans when I did my special
incorrigible and this guy was like
literally that guy that I was talking
about man he did the neck slit
thing like come on dude if I said you go
to Miami gonna see a Cuban do the neck
slit thing you'd be like I'm not in a
movie this guy did it did it was so
funny uh yeah but I forgot to talk about
that last week and he was he was talking
about how and then and he was one of
those guys where he was talking like
that and he was this time like he was 49
years old but he seemed like he was just
like us like a kid I mean I'm not a kid
but that's how I think I am in my head
and then he told me he had kid kids and
how he was telling his son this I
was like man this guy is a
ruthless dad dude how Cuban is it to
like to like tell your
seven-year-old like about you
know to be like my friend you got it to
call your son my friend first of all my
son Fran Lizzy
you gotta get this possum ah but you're
gonna do this man you gotta get this
possum and you gotta be aggressive I do
got a beef oh that's what he said you
that's what he said there he's like you
gotta be smooth man you gotta be smooth
that's what he kept saying you gotta be
smooth you can't Colorado
you can't Colorado you gotta be smooth
he said it probably 40 times and I was
like ah so smooth huh
yeah man you gotta be smooth man
otherwise the next lip thing a cuban god
damn um anyway dude woke up today and
trying to live that montage lifestyle
and I'm living that montage lifestyle
and I'm I've been shooting alone
together I was shooting a log dude let
me tell you this other thing too I've
been shooting alone together and
yesterday I had to know like two days
ago three days ago I did this by shot
all day and they put my character in a
knee brace so I get to just sit
down and be in bed during my scenes oh
come on dude I made it I'm in Hollywood
baby and I don't even have to enter
scenes I just got a lay down in bed and
be in a wheelchair and have a my
girlfriend in the show this hot chick
wheels me around yeah I made it babies
and I get to be on TV
I made it dude and I couldn't even get
up to get out of the wheelchair because
I had the neck brace on it keeps your
leg stiff as so I'd be like hey man
could I get coffee they'd go get it for
me hedonistic lifestyle dude I've got
new ideas for the cult I'm like Jesus
man I used to think that Daniel
day-lewis was so good in my left foot
that dude
got to relax for 14 hours a
day only at the move was his left foot
sign me the up dude we got to do a
few scenes where we cry and say
like me off man he got the Oscar
for that he got nominated bro that
you know who should get nominated and
win every year Tom Cruise cuz he never
doesn't run in movies that guy is the
most fit guy ever cuz he's got to run
all day in movies you know what people
think that
making movies is like so exciting it's
literally the most boring thing in the
world do you know how many scenes even
if you're a lead how many scenes you're
actually like doing actual acting think
about how many little scenes or movies
where you walk into a room and
pick up a document and then or like see
something you know how long that takes
to film that scene eight hours if you're
on Mission Impossible that takes
eight hours to film you're walking into
a room picking up a document and then
walking out of the room that
takes eight hours no
there's it takes it definitely takes at
least five you want to be that
you know how many scenes
who you're actually acting in a movie
like mission impossible 3 and those
things are not so there's three days
where you're doing that and the shoots
four months long they split up
that skyscraper scene where he's running
across the did when you actors who
do their own stunts that kills me
did we talk about this let's talk about
this yet I did who the would do
their own stunts man that doesn't
impress me at all that makes me think
you're a dingbat
dude get somebody else on the micro
motorcycle as a matter of fact if I have
to do anything but be in that wheelchair
or lay in bed
get me a stunt double I don't give a
get me a stunt double oh dude what
is he doing he's got to enter a room
get me a stunt double I don't
want to this up walking can be
dangerous for real but you know what I
would never do get a naked body double
some dudes get these naked body doubles
or the chicks do - no way if you're
gonna see my ass or in movie you're
gonna see that real thing you're
gonna see that real thing baby oh dude I
was in I got my buddy a guest pass to uh
my gym and I got the via I got what we
were in the locker room and and I
was like dude I'm gonna take a shower
afterwards I'm just gonna rinse off and
he was like all right cool I took all my
clothes off and then I walked over to
the shower he's like what are you doing
me and my was out slap it
on the side when I walk my goes
back to that pat pat on the side
of my legs cuz his largest
it just was pat pat
Papp while I'm walking I got to make
sure - sometimes lifts it up so it
doesn't drag on their ground but it goes
pop on the side of my thighs and
I'm walking and he's like what the
are you doing dude and I'm like what
he's like you just gonna walk around
naked I said yo bro this is the locker
room man what am I gonna do cover it
with my hand did I cover my all of
the time all of the days but I gotta go
to am/pm
I gotta cover my I get to be in one
place in public where I don't cover my
and I'm gonna cover my
that man if you're behind me you see my
if you're in front of me you see
my and I don't cover it I walk
regular I walk regular with my hands by
my side sometimes I put my hands through
my hair while I'm walking my hands are
up bro
all day long in front of me pat pat
pat pat pat you hear it you see it dude
you get the full experience this is
IMAX 3d in the locker room if
somebody looks at me I make
straight heterosexual eye contact with
them I don't around look at Mike if
they look at my I look back I go
that's what happened baby that's what
God gave me I got that pat pat
pat I got that PAP dude I
don't
you know I'm not covering my enough
in the locker room I'm not covering my
in a locker room dude
that's a good Eminem lyric cover
mechanic in the locker room who covers
the tank in the locker room
I'm not the kind of guy who comes with
characters like you gotta see my little
penis Amina Sabine Athena go home I do
not mix me up with a guy okay dude he
rubs everything for real
none of that rhymes do not mix me up and
again okay and his lack of room and
everyone's like whoa how does he find
everything that rhymes he doesn't dude
you never find a penis to mean it's deep
Dene that's a penis only nabina the name
is marina Williams you think your penis
of being a Serena Williams Serena
Williams doesn't run with penis you know
Forrest Gump and an orange Trump you're
like all right I guess who's on my
phone's gonna know what's wrong but I'm
thinking what a man is gonna come from a
Cadillac boom penis do you see my penis
between wings and dude and 45
year old white dudes are like that's
so good
how forty-five years old is it too like
Eminem and and think he's the best
rapper I'm not talking on Eminem dude
the guy's one of the best rappers of all
time it's just so funny to think of a 45
year old guy named like Derrick that's
just like oh man Eminem is the greatest
rapper right like that you know what
that is that's so la Kenyatta dad to
think Eminem is it so it's so dad from
Pasadena to be like Eminem is is is
great because he's a lyricist like
it's but some of this stuff is poetry
some of his stuff is poetry you know a
guy a white guy who's 45 that has beige
hair and wears Dockers has said that a
million guys like that have said that
literally a million I don't know I'm not
really in into his when he's talking
about penis and Serena Williams but you
know that in a locker room
lyric mm-hm yeah but like you don't get
to show your in public at all I'm
walking around in the in the locker room
with my hands up like about a
rap show put your hands up put your
hands up put your hands up like you in
the locker room and you ain't got no
pants on and krystal it put your hands
up put your hands I'm playing you in
lanky crystalline lack of a character
well I mean it's the bad it's bad you
got going his head off do gonna go to
you know yeah how it does surprise you
don't like with that Cuban guy it does
surprise I don't even know how I got to
that locker room story but it does
surprise you - with the it does surprise
you sometimes when you hear of people
how about when you know somebody for
like months and then you find out they
have kids for like you're like what that
person has kids like like I don't think
he has kids but like a guy like Jared
Leto like will you be like oh he has a
kid and I didn't know you know guys like
that I only get years have a kid but um
but uh I I was thinking about no I was
thinking about actually kids and having
kids I never knew if I want to kid you
not sometimes in my life like I'd go
through years Rob's like oh I want a kid
and sometimes I'd be like no I don't
want to have a kid because I love my
life and that would only ruin it I mean
everybody talked to that as kids is like
don't have
listen you know that quote people will
show you who you who they are so let
them you know that stupid as
quote um but yeah to have kids like
some people want kids just cuz they want
to have a baby you know and that baby
grows up and they're just the worst
mother ever or whatever but then some
people want kids because they want to
see a little of them you know it's like
a selfish thing to have kids
sometimes like it really is
it's definitely irresponsible for the
world to have a bunch of kids I mean
some of these like Mormons
just like hey let's have 12
I got enough raspberry sauce for all of
them but like 12 like 12 kids what do
you hey if you have 12 kids what are you
doing if you have eight kids
what are you doing hey if you have four
kids what are you doing you know what
have one or two kids have three kids
maybe if you're so rich if you have four
kids go to Antarctica you have
to live there
congratulations have a colony there and
now everyone with over three kids has to
live in Antarctica you did it you made
your bed lay in it but you know
you want have a family fine why do
people want kids
women nurture you know so I get why they
want to have kids because they want to
experience motherhood but that's so
weird that's still selfish no matter
what I go back to it always feels
selfish to have kids unless you just
nut in a girl by mistake and
she's like I'm having it and you're like
are cool I don't believe in abortion and
I did squirt bony inside you
I did inside you sorry let's
have it
see you nine months I don't know if I
want to have kids to have imagine having
a little you dude if you don't have kids
imagine for a second actually having a
little you you
I know it's half you have someone else
but you imagine it's you mostly and that
like that's the other thing too like
when I have a kid like I'm so up
with my hang with my anxiety or whatever
my OCD if I have a kid like I'm so
specific dude you know me you listen to
my you know how I am you know I
don't these rules and that
I'm joking about and all that I'm kind
of also serious a little bit newsflash
I'm serious you know but like to have a
kid and have him be like having a little
kid for me to have a look at it's like
no I don't like to eat pasta with sauce
on it because that's something else I'll
put the sauce on the side
I will have the pasta and I will dip as
much sauce as I want on each bite if I
had like a three-year-old that was
saying that I'd be like Oh for
sake dude well maybe yell at him
that's what I do in a way not that but
you know when I go I get a brownie
sundae I tell him to split all the
up man I don't want you to do it you
give me the things I how much
percentage of what goes in my mouth you
think I'm joking about that dude
so I have a kid that's like no I don't
want to wear shorts and long-sleeve
shirts because that doesn't make sense
and I'm like but this is what you have
the other shit's dirty it doesn't matter
I don't wear that I wear shorts and
short sleeves are long pants and long
sleeves I'm gonna be like no I'm gonna
get it oh my god
sake so that is two of us that
have to go by rules because I
go by my rules and then I see my kid and
I'm like I gotta go by his rules too cuz
I respect that OCD lifestyle
then I have two or three kids we all got
rules literally I just gotta be that
guy with the leg brace in bed
not hey kids let's just not move all day
get post mates and we won't have to obey
any rules okay dad
four beds in one room me no wife
cuz she left way before way after the
each kid with a different girl
cuz they got so fed up with all of us
after after the kid came out and started
talking she's like well I can't deal
with both of you and then
I got a new chick inside of her
and then got a new chick inside of her
three kids four beds one big studio one
big studio apartment just like kids to
wake up good morning gentlemen
remember let's not move at all if anyone
needs anything I will do it I've been
dealing with this anxiety as long as
longer than all of you put together okay
dad we'll just stay here remember stay
here till 10:00 p.m. and then we'll go
back to sleep all we do is eat and
out of the hole in the bed okay how do
we pee you take your PAP and you
just point it since we all have big
cuz I've got a big and I've
passed that down to everybody except
Craig over on the left dad how come my
character is so small I don't know maybe
your mom's dad's was small we were
hoping it would skip a generation
whatever I'll just piss up into the air
your penis is
Craig your penis is not big enough and
it sticks straight up because of it I'll
just pay higher dad okay put on Netflix
Tommy okay and then they get to be and
that's just what we do that's how we do
till one of the kids is just like man I
don't like this lifestyle I'm moving out
and then he gets out feels that
son what I won't - got-damn up be hard
to handle like flame okay no and then
some homeless guy talk to him
and spits on him and he said and he
thinks I should never have left home I
got to go back home I like in
the bed butters looking at me like you
know what man I got two dogs I'm gonna
do it with an ADD break first
you guys tripping you deal with tripping
it's awesome did you know that the
average family visits five totally
different websites before booking a
vacation rental I travel all the time
and I love traveling I like going to
different places if you book with TripIt
you spend less time planning your next
trip and more time relaxing with TripIt
calm I'm going on a place I'm going to a
place in about a month just gonna relax
trip it is tripping have I been saying
trip it the whole time I'll this
man I gotta start over with this
ad now and we're not cutting it
out do it just pretend I didn't say that
remember that trip it you
remember that we were kid trip that
trip it and it you would keep
one little thing in the thing and you I
mean what skip it
it wasn't trip it I'm wrong about that
too for sake dude my dogs think
I'm mad at him cuz I'm yelling hey guys
tripping have you tried it it's a great
website to be brutally honest with you
because I like to go
and book my drips with it the average
family visits five totally different
websites before booking a vacation
rental that's the truth dude you know I
only speak the truth here on this
podcast but when I use tripping which
I'm using it for my next thing I'm going
somewhere in a month to just relax but
you can spend less time planning your
next trip and more time relaxing with
tripping calm the world's number one
site for vacation rentals tripping calm
is trusted by millions of travelers and
featured by New York Times Travel and
Leisure Forbes and more if you're
looking for a cabin which one day we are
babies or a beachfront home to get away
to this winter we're already looking
ahead to vacations for the spring
tripping calm can happen can help you
find the perfect place to stay it really
can I've used it and I will use it again
it saves time tripping calm onesearch
lets you filter compare and sort over 10
million available properties untrusted
sites like verbo TripAdvisor booking
calm and more don't wonder if you're
getting the best deal you'll save an
average of 18% per night by booking your
vacation with trippin comm so don't
forget if you want to save time and
money while booking the perfect vacation
rental for your next trip head to
trippin comm / Congrats today that's T
RI PP ing comm / Congrats trippin comm /
Congrats square cache look if you
haven't heard we've switched to the
cache yep that's what we use that's what
we use with the call it's the simplest
way to pay people back friends family
babies elders sending and receiving
money is totally free and fast and most
payments can be deposited directly to
your bank account in just a few seconds
the cash app also lets you buy and sell
Bitcoin instantly get your paycheck
deposited right to the app pull money
out of the ATM with the free custom cash
card or use it to spend anywhere you
like you're not gonna find another
useful find another more useful finance
app out there you really not design your
cards and tweet us a pic so we could see
them I've seen a few cool designs some
of them are art aliy horrible but those
are even better okay people write CUDA
with no no put a barracuda with a
no-smoking sign in front of it or
whatever that is
like a note Cooter's own and of course
when you download the cash app five
dollars goes to you and five dollars
goes to time's up the Legal Defense Fund
so not only not only is it free you get
five dollars and you donate five dollars
come on man
you're going to heaven just because of
that download the free cash app for iOS
or Android now I am my dog's look at I
realized okay I have two dogs one is Sam
and one is butters hi guys Sam looks at
me like I like he's never me and
wants to me so bad that's what he
looks at me like butters looks at me
like I him constantly and he looks
at me like he's he's like he doesn't
want it but he also doesn't want it like
he looks back at me a lot like Sam looks
at me like this if you look in the video
podcast but butters looks at me all the
time like this like he's Trina or some
hey Bob us hi come here come here
Oh butters hi Sam you're down there this
is butters time I always you always
get some time dude
hold them butters video podcast time
dude chill you like me how about when
you hold your dogging to try to get away
you're like no no no you like me my dogs
ran away and then they came back that's
the most ridiculous thing ever
that's like so me of a dog but anyway uh
yeah so I don't know if I'm having a
little me like a kid
Wow people adopt that's that's
definitely responsible I wonder I don't
think I would ever adopt I think I would
well not that I wouldn't adopt but I
think it was gonna have kids I would do
it
by coming in a girl and then having it
nine months later
that the medical way to say that you
come in a girl doctor hello she's me
doctor I'm gonna have a baby you think I
should do the one where I adopt or I
come in a girl and then she has it nine
months later sir you need to leave the
waiting room already not the doctor I'm
the receptionist okay
can I make an appointment no can I know
do you know if can you leave sir yes I'm
sorry
you bring up one medical term I didn't
know you know how long it took me to
love my dogs years they were just dogs
when people love dogs immediately if you
have a dog for six months and then it
runs away and you cry I don't get it it
takes me years to love a dog my last dog
I mean don't get me wrong I love these
dogs now dude oh my god I need them but
my last dog Hank I had him with my
ex-wife when we split she moved out and
this was 11 years ago or ten years ago
anyway I can't live with ten
years ago she left and the left the dog
with me because she was just kind of
like gonna go do her own thing we
separated and then I had Hank and I I
liked Hank a lot he was a great dog he's
still alive she's got him but he's a
great dog and he was a Havanese which
are like my favorite breed no offense
guys four little dogs at least one my
favorite my favorite and so he threw the
break-up I was with that dog all the
time I was spending it alone with him
which was the first time because it was
usually me and her and him I mean her
name and she let left me
you know I guess and I was with the dog
for a year and I remember I don't
remember the month she left me but I do
remember the
fourth-of-july I was sitting on my couch
in alone with my dog holding Hank and I
was watching fireworks on TV and this is
when I was getting going through my
divorce and and I felt so content
that I had my dog and was just watching
fireworks on TV but it made me feel good
that I had this dog and I also realized
that the dog helped me through the
divorce and it made me feel like a real
person and I realized how much I loved
that dog in that moment because I didn't
really think about it until then because
it was just a dog you know I'm like this
guy that like doesn't let you know I
don't I don't really think about it like
that I don't like I don't you know like
what I'm like what's love it's just when
you like somebody a lot right
but I remember staring at that those
fireworks and holding that dog and
thinking wow it sucks that I'm going
through this divorce but there's kind of
nowhere I'd rather be right now and I'm
and and I wouldn't want I don't wanna be
out on 4th of July with anybody I'm
happy with my dog and I love my dog and
I started crying not like
bawling like Robert De Niro in the
mission but like just like a little bit
and I was like but it was because I was
like sad and happy I've never been as
sad and as equally equally as sad and
equally as happy as I was in that moment
but it was cool man there was a
nice moment in my life it was it was a
poignant moment in my life I remember
when I got I remember when I got
divorced I kind of like when I first got
with my ex her you know she like we I
when we were boyfriend and girlfriend I
did I started doing stand-up and then
you know because I always wanted to do
it
and then it became my life it and it
still is and it's my whole life is my
stand-up and I've had relationships come
and go because of my stand-up I've had
friendships deteriorate because I don't
hang out with them anymore because I'm a
stand-up and I can't go to things like
weddings because I have kegs in
Alabama and and it's what I want to
do man and I do feel bad sometimes that
I miss out on those things but I won't
not do it I mean I gotta do stand-up and
[Music]
so that's fine you got to shake hands
with who you are but I remember my
marriage was dissolving and my and I was
getting divorced and I think I was
divorced at this point anyway I got my
first had a hundred tell his story I
haven't told this story in a long time
so when I was with my ex-wife we did a
show I was with Jo koy he brought his
wife I was opening for him and we were
in Miami and we had like a little
vacation slash hanging out in Miami
doing shows and also like hung out and
sin when that then after that we got our
marriage dissolved or whatever and then
I got my first like real headlining gig
it was for a college is for Miami
University University of Miami I don't
know what they call it but which I
recently played again on my birthday
last week but I played this I got it I
got they were gonna pay me a little bit
of money to fly down I brought an opener
with me and I did this this school I
performed for the school and I was being
getting divorced and I was walking we
just took a walk after the show me and
my opener and as we were walking to down
the street I look up and we're literally
standing right in front of the hotel
that I stayed in with my ex-wife and I
was like wow
how crazy is this that I didn't know I
was here but I look up and Here I am
this is where we stayed I remember
staying this saying with her whatever
was like three years ago
and now I don't have this marriage
anymore and it's because there's a lot
of it is because of the stand-up and
because of the selfishness I had because
I needed to do stand-up when I should
have probably been doing the marriage
right and I looked up and I thought I
will this is one of those it was it all
worth it moments you know like this is
the the almost the end of the movie
where you're looking at it and you're
like man I gave one thing up for another
thing literally and Here I am back where
I was
location-wise when I had that last thing
and now I have this new thing was it all
worth it I remember clearly thinking was
this all worth it
giving up my marriage and basically
embarking on this stand-up career and
the answer was hard to come up with but
the answer is a little bit that's the
answer that's the answer is yeah it was
a little bit worth it now now if I go
there I would say Oh a hundred percent
wildly worth it because I have what I
have I've built this whole you know life
but in three years it was a little bit
worth it
I got to do my first headlining gig and
[Music]
it was it was it was it was one of those
moments like I was sitting with the dog
where I was like oh well I'm I'm equally
as happy as I am sad but I was a little
bit happier than I was sad because I was
like I'm a professional comedian now and
I did it and my marriage failed but I
was able to do and succeed in what I
wanted to do and now I've ever see gone
way beyond that this was eight nine
years ago I've achieved much more so
the answer is way more than a little bit
now I mean I'm happy as I
love my life
you know and you don't have to many
people say that so I'm fortunate man and
I got two new dogs I got my two
little buddies and Hank is still out
there he's with his new little family
it's a sad when you say it like that but
it's cool because I know that that was
better for him anyway because I I I was
uh what do you call it on the road all
the time and
I don't know he would have been dead for
sure if I watched him and he was always
in my apartment dude I had a
corner of the apartment where he were
just going
I had a doggie door he was like he was
like oh that's cute I don't use doggy
doors catch you later
in the corner the carpet was so rough
because he would piss there too so awful
dude I mean I I sold the place I had to
recarpet whole thing actually I didn't
sell the place I have the place I rent
it out I'm a property owner dude
do you know you're with man I
got places I don't know why I started
talking about my life ten years
ago
sorry for pouring the out of you
without comedy but the first half was
was good it was fun hey guys guess what
I'm sweating like a let's
do some Twitter questions dude I got
funny I got serious dude we're
practically in the lobby log cabin
you're a part of this cult and you're
free conch I know you can do any cult
you want you don't have to be in a cult
it's free conch but you're in this one
so welcome you're you're accepted you're
accepted almost threw up when I said
that very cold oh no what happened okay
this
not CUDA but people don't know what CUDA
means I keep telling you Brock Chrisman
JB Chrisman 22 or some that's too
many
he writes Chris Aaliyah and even more
CUDA thing I heard this is not a CUDA
thing he's got the wrong meaning of CUDA
but people call McDonald's cause we're
talking about McCall McDonald's Mickey
D's call McDonald's growing up Ronnie
Mac's a steakhouse dude imagine someone
saying hey you want to go to Ronnie Mac
Steakhouse let's go and you're like yeah
cool whatever and you go there and they
bring in a McDonald's you're like what
the you talking about you said it
was Ronnie Mac oh that's how that goes
you'd be like you said it was Ronnie Mac
oh I get it
Ronnie Mac's steakhouse like don't use I
don't like when they call things you
know I don't like when they call things
new things to be cute you know what else
I don't like when people and when when
here's the other thing
how about what how about when
apartment complexes aren't called just
like 660 428 Wilshire they're called
like yeah I live at the Camden what go
yourself you're an apartment
complex you're not a event
you're not a Ronnie Mac Steakhouse
that's what i'ma call my house hey let's
meet at Ronnie Mac's steakhouse where is
it oh yeah it's this address al what um
now go the other one was the last one
that one at Chris D'Elia when men named
their son after themselves so first of
all so drunk it says it seems so pompous
to me it's a drunk name their sons after
themselves is seem so pompous to me she
means it seems so pompous to me in your
wise opinion which it won't be wise is
its to name your child after
yourself well dude that's the definition
of saqqaq hey my name is Chris I'm gonna
name a son Chris and guess what we're
gonna do make
confusing at the household but by the by
the way besides that doesn't matter
because I'm the it's a I don't
care how confused everybody is I mean
and I want them to be me too yeah it's a
that's by Lindsey stove which is a
crazy last name at Lindsey stove she got
it
is it is pompous and I don't like it and
I would never name my kid Chris however
George Foreman named all his sons George
baller if you're gonna do one kid do
them all do George Foreman is the man
for that hey George how do i how do I
get my invention going try invent him a
lot of my friends say hey George
whatever that commercial is invent help
commercial every time I'm on the road
try invent here
it's invent to help they had to put it
on the screen while he was saying of
course because he says if it here hey
say it right you know they were like
George George George and one of his sons
was like yeah and they're like no not
you George
can you say invent help and he says yeah
dad about friends ask me hey George how
do I get my idea off the ground and I
say try invent here Oh God okay I'll
talk to him excuse me hey George his
other son yeah no not you George first
of all why are you bringing all your
sons to set but can you not say NVIDIA
and say invent help and then one of his
other son says sure and says no no I'm
not talking you I'm actually talking to
your father
god dammit can you guys can all of you
guys kind of go into the other room
while I talk to this one George me know
you're the fourth son god damn it I'm
trying to talk your father get everybody
excuse me
the ad is named George - and he's not
even in the family excuse me George come
over here yeah no not you goddammit you
know what this is getting very confusing
you stay there
behind the camera George yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah no God why did you bring
all your sons you George you George the
George Foreman the first one stay there
I'm not talking to you
you know what just say invent
here I don't care just can you EDI McCoy
ad because I it's really we should have
hired you because I didn't know you'll
bring all of his sons go into the other
room
bring everyone else with the same name
in the other room not please say invent
help okay
they just does it worse not and action
a lot of my friends say hey George how
do I get my idea off the ground and I
say try it here okay cut we got it we'll
do it fine it's fine
it he's not doing it he's saying in
Vinita she's making it sound Asian
England here but that's a baller ship
tecora anoint him George and the fact
that it's George is this to like
he's some like Asian guy that moved from
Korea to America that cycle they they
still use those names
that's dude how it's so funny I think
I've talked about this on the podcast
but like how Asian like I went to
logging out it was at such a popular
Asian like community there's half Asians
and and they would have names like Henry
because they thought that's what like
theirs
their parents thought that that's what
like people were named when it's not
like nobodies it'd be like like like
Gregory you know and girls names would
be Grace or like Mary you know
like whose name is Mary that was to me
that's like that was like the first name
oh so there was self like Henry was such
an Asian name and George George dude
um what any another one um let me see
okay we go Sabrina at gangsta brunch
change it that's the one that yeah I
know her I think I met her in Ohio I
have a degree in screenwriting and
although I no longer work in the
industry I've decided to write your
Japanese man action figure I've never
been more serious in my life
all right let me do it it's probably
gonna be real bad you know you got to
put a demon in it like she said there's
a follow-up I will put a demon in it
yeah I'll do it
ha this is good sherry at fully
underscore wooly - well I mean I'm not
even gonna say it well I got it change
it fully wooly - yeah
someone had fully woolly one you know
how is it and in quotes and s
white to blow on your food before eating
it yeah
even if she writes even more so if
you're at a restaurant yeah it is pretty
white it is pretty white I feel like if
you're Japanese you just put that
thing in your mouth and no
matter how hot it is and you deal with
it
you put anybody but hold on it's racist
oh I've talked about this this is this
is a quote goon King at what does that
say Sheridan King dude nobody
cares if you take a break from social
media shut the up you don't have
fans you don't gotta update us you're
just a person Kay yeah I either tweeted
that before something like that or set
it on the podcast yeah dude yeah I think
I said on the podcast who gives a
you don't have to talk about taking a
break
see ya oh no you know what I talk about
on the podcast sorry I haven't posted in
a while what uh was it no when they said
when somebody says sorry I haven't
posted in a while guys but you don't
have to that's what I was talking about
you don't apologize for not posting who
gives a I'll go back and look at
your last posts mostly it's just the
girls taking pictures of their ass where
they're turned around anyway sorry I
haven't posted pictures of my backside
oh really you fart out of that hey thank
you know what that's what here's here's
a call to action for four babies pick
girls who post pictures of their ass on
Instagram go under and comment oh cool
you fart out of that exclamation point
or hey wait a minute you fart out of
that exclamation point or thanks for
posting the picture up thanks for
posting a picture of the thing you fart
out of exclamation point you got to put
the exclamation point on it and hashtag
congratulations pod that's your call to
action all right we got an elder you
said all right one fire coming through
with the elder new elders and we were
just talking about this person gray
silymarin dragon Eddie Jesus Christ what
is she a superhero that's her name
gray silymarin dragon Eddie and Sabrina
Taylor who was just gangsta brunch
Sabrina Taylor admin this is why they're
at administration administrator and
moderator admin and moderator of the
congratulations Facebook group which it
has like 500 members in it now I don't
know what it is but there's a quiz you
have to take to get in it so I think a
lot of people don't know the questions
I'm not sure if they both started the
group or what but since they're both on
the masthead they there they're now both
elders so we'll get you your information
on Twitter we'll DM it to you and all
that and thanks for the upkeep with the
page it's I I I'm a member of it and I
check it on I see it on Facebook it
always pops up and it's pretty funny and
it's cool when you guys share a lot of
stuff on there and it's it's nice as a
community for it for all of the for the
cult it's nice that there's a community
for a cult anyway that's about it I got
I don't have any of the other last page
of the thing but I do I have to do I
don't have to do the thing
whoops square cache if you haven't heard
we already had that oh here we go
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now that was the only one I had
yeah okay I was so nervous
one fargo's okay it's not I was in his
backpack check out this week's wait
really blue apron this gun dude
one fire in full effect goes oh no sorry
just the next one square cache have you
switched yet
download the free square cash app enter
rewards code congrats and get five
dollars and give five dollars - times up
get it for iOS or Android now and you
know what why not
I still love blue apron so go ahead and
get that guy follow-the-leader
bite look he thinks he's gonna make up
for it - because you made a little nice
little square thing around my dates that
doesn't make it better do it
it's the first time I put the square
thing around my dates to make it easier
to read not cool first leg
second leg force of all he didn't put
the - squirt let he didn't split
up the legs dude this guy you know what
he tries to do before gonna do something
nice he didn't split up the legs he put
some of the second leg with the
first leg column anyway Pittsburgh
Dayton Huntsville Nashville Denver Boise
Eugene Oregon
Sacramento Red Bank Wilmington re-read
it I don't know if it's reading a
reading reading a Pennsylvania Tulsa
Midwest City Dallas Portland Hampton
Beach Mashantucket Houston Wichita
Kansas City Lincoln Reno Las Vegas and
were also adding more cities to the
third leg it's too many cities but
that's my job
don't worry about it that's my job just
get your tickets and attend a cult
meeting subscribe to the YouTube channel
download the Chris D'Elia app for iOS or
Android and that can you can see the
podcast before it goes up rate review
the show please it really helps out if
you do that on iTunes that helped
video episodes go up Tuesdays or
Wednesday's subscribe to the YouTube
channel and and that's it thanks for
listening and remember if you got that
PAP just try to live that montage
lifestyle
[Music]